I've done as Rodman about to answer
during internet the Internet what's the
worst thing you've gotten thrown out of
a bar for the worst thing I've got
thrown of a bar it's a lot there's a lot
give me one
pushing the girl why my wife having
cocaine with another girl I'll do it
do it would you rather have a threesome
with two midgets midgets or two for you
42 7-foot tall girls almost had sex with
a [ __ ] and a paraplegic
that counts at the same time yeah so
what a guy in my house upstairs in the
beach yep that definitely counts I had
Nokia hello hello a delicious dough
hello delicious I'm carrying a political
upstairs right there the measures of the
hole in my [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you you
having sex with a [ __ ] has to be a
disaster oh it's gotta be [ __ ] almost
so you did well almost why almost was
obvious my guilt Wow
so you do have a line you know I do have
one that's it you couldn't [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm surprised I thought you were
too [ __ ] many [ __ ] i thought you
would have [ __ ] several minutes well i
could have would you rather get a good
hand job from your grandma or a bad hand
job from your grandma aunt used to do it
a lot she said put your friends down let
me see your dick once and what the [ __ ]
all of a sudden L said really
really girl like that it's like that TV
show voodoo today right
all the cousin the cousin oh my aunt
sucking my dick what the [ __ ] sorry
that's like a grandma you are a wild boy
Dennis Rodman if you could have one
athlete in their prime on your team for
the rest of your life who would it be
done is Rob
yeah what STD would you be willing to
have if you were able to pass it on to
your worst enemy so you got to have it
but you also get to give it to the
person you hate the most
Richard Peddie sure is that who it is
Richard Petty yes STP right SSTP that's
all right I'd say lubrication STD what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is STD i sexually
transmitted disease
alright I find it very hard to believe
you don't know what STD I know I know
the [ __ ] it is man I never had a disease
you know but which one you willing to
have to pass it on pass it on pass it on
child support
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]